Olha só essa jogada de marketing da
Coca-Cola. Ela vai trocar xarope de
milho por açúcar de cana nos Estados
Unidos. E tem gente comemorando, achando
que agora ficou saudável. Pois é, parece
piada, mas não é. Veja bem, tanto xarope
de milho quanto açúcar de cana são
praticamente a mesma coisa pro seu
corpo. Açúcar simples, puro, sem nenhum
nutriente. É como trocar seis por meia
dúzia. Mas o problema não é só o açúcar,
não. O refrigerante tem um coquetel de
substâncias que atacam a sua saúde,
ácido fosfórico que enfraquece seus
ossos, cafeína que mexe com a sua
pressão, corante caramelo que pode até
aumentar risco de câncer e um monte de
químicos que inflamam o seu corpo por
dentro. Então não importa se é açúcar de
cana, de milho ou de beterraba.
Refrigerante continua sendo veneno
líquido. Cada latinha é uma bomba de
calorias vazias que aumenta o seu risco
de diabetes, obesidade, problema nos
rins e no coração.